nintendo is finally venturing into the  world of mobile games but a lot of  people were underwhelmed by the reveal  of me tomo fortunately current president  and CEO tatsumi kimishima has teased  something much better for the next game  during an earnings call the president  said the next game will not be a  communication app and that its star is a  well-known Nintendo character now we  just need to figure out who that  character is when it comes to Nintendo  you've got superstars like mario zelda  link Donkey Kong and so many more to  choose from I guess we'll just have to  wait for an official announcement me  tomo is set to arrive this year in  nintendo is planning a lineup of five  mobile games by 2017 whenever they  announce the others you'll hear about it  on gamespot in the meantime there's  always puzzling dragons